what is that
hundreds of people tortured to death
shot peaceful people bodies on streets
minds around houses and even dead bodies
everywhere looting concentrated evil
came to our country murderers rapists
robbers looters that call themselves an
army and they all deserve the death
penalty after what they've done
we believe that russian forces have
committed
war crimes and we've been working to to
document that
to provide the information that we have
to the relevant institutions and
organizations
that will put all this together and
there needs to be accountability for it
the murder of civilians is a war crime
we must relentlessly investigate these
crimes committed by the russian armed
forces
the perpetrators and those in charge of
them must be held accountable
[Music]
so
what we see in european and what we see
in bucha are horrible images and
unfortunately these images are not from
a film but reality the aggressor will
pay for everything a great price for the
lives of thousands of ukrainians we will
not forgive what has been done to our
cities and our residents
[Music]
you